[Music]
hey everyone thanks very much for
joining today
my name is Fergus Hurley and I'm the
product manager for Android vitals I'm
really excited to talk to you today
about the past present and future of
android vitals so to start off what is
Android Wales I'm sure a lot of you guys
are aware of it already but just to make
sure
Android BIOS is Google's initiative to
help improve the stability and
performance of Android devices have we
doing a lot of different things to be
able to improve this one big part of it
is within the Play console we now have a
section called Android vials and that's
where we report to you different
performance metrics we're going to we're
gonna cover in this talk how do we
actually power this product is an
interesting question to start off with
well hundreds of millions of users have
opted into sharing their device usage
and Diagnostics data with at Google and
you are partners and so we share that
data in a privacy compliant way within
the product I am start by going through
some lessons we've learned over the last
18 months since we launched files at i/o
last year from top developers out there
that are big and small and that have
actually used Android vials and got a
lot of success from using it so hands up
here who wants less one star ratings
okay if you don't have your hand if you
might be at the wrong conference
unfortunately I place most people - it
won't avoid them and what we found when
we looked at the review corpus on Google
Play which is pretty large eye is that
40% of all one-star reviews where we
extracted topic are talking about
stability and bugs and over the past
year the percentage of users talking
about civilian bugs in the reviews has
gone down by 18 percent it was pretty
amazing
and so we're gonna talk about some of
the developers who have actually
contributed to this reduction the emerge
dragons team which is behind a very
popular Zenga game they used Android
viola studio to pinpoint where
specifically there was an issue with
their application and this resulted in
them be able to reduce their one-star
reviews by 5th
d % the very popular read adapt used
Android vials to be able to reduce their
crash rate by 75% and they did this
because they were able to see the
category benchmarks in the Play console
Android viola section and that was able
to make the case with their leadership
that they were had room for improvement
and then when they actually improved
their metric they were able to show
leadership
hey we've actually had only set out to
do and now we're one of the most stable
apps out there the Lavo team signed up
for the anomaly alert emails in the play
console and as a result they got
notified as soon as there was an issue
with the N or rate of their application
they had a huge spike caused by an SDK
that they were using in their
application and even though you might be
building an amazing product yourself and
think that it's very stable I'm sure you
use third-party libraries and some of
those could introduce issues in your
application so you want to become aware
of these things as soon as possible and
the anomaly alert emails help you
without a lot they quickly disabled the
ads SK that was causing the issue and
then they shifted a new fix that
actually reduced their a and or a back
down to 0.25 percent the ABA English
team is pretty small team and they don't
have infinite resources to be able to
spend on performance and we don't think
that you spent all your time focusing on
performance either well we realized that
you have to keep an eye on performance
all the time and that it might make
sense for you to take a quarter to
actually just focus on improving the
performance of your application and hold
off on doing features maybe we do that
as part of your 2019 q1 planning are do
a spring clean after q2 of next year at
the ABA English team did this and they
spent one quarter focused effort and
reduce their ARH by 97% as a result this
and a bunch of other things resulted in
them being able to increase their star
rating to 4.6 stars
now obviously you can't get a 4.6 star
rating but just focusing on files but we
guarantee that you will never get such a
high rating if you have terrible files
okay so I've gone through some examples
of individual app developers
using violence what we've actually also
done is we looked at of the top thousand
apps on play-i we looked at their
engagement in the viola section since IO
and we found is that the developers who
engaged most in the violin section like
the top 10% they reduced their crash
rate by 50% over that time period and
this isn't just good for those
developers in those apps this is really
good for Android end users this resulted
in three billion more stable installs on
the platform so we talked about
stability I another major area that
users talk about I when they leave
one-star reviews is resource usage
issues and this is battery network
memory etc and we have many metrics in
the file section around battery and some
of these metrics are interrelated so one
of the metrics we have is excessive
network usage in the background and so
this is bad for users in two ways it's
consuming their data plan and it's
wasting their battery in the background
we have two metrics that we especially
focus on in this area there are wake
up's and wakelocks and I'll come back to
them in a bit but the jam or team
focused on their wake up's rate and what
they say is that they wouldn't have even
noticed our being able to fix their
excessive wake up's issue without using
Android violence because we have a lot
of insights into your battery usage that
there are very few other tools that can
actually help you with and this resulted
in Deming out to reduce their excessive
wake up rate by 70% great now we're
gonna jump over to how you can actually
increase your five-star reviews and what
we find is that over the past year we've
had more users mentioning speed design
and usability which is what 70% of the
five-star reviews talked about when we
are able to find topics in them the
mikado Libre team which is one of the
largest e-commerce apps in the world
it's number one in Latin America they
were building a new feature into their
application they required them to ask
for a specific permission
this resulted in a bad user experience
where users actually result had a very
high denial rate of this permission they
were to see that in Android vials and
then be able to redesign that feature to
give users an explanation of why they
needed it and that permission and only
asked when the users actually really
needed that for that specific feature
and not really early on in the process
my counter Libre team is pretty big team
and one of the things they found very
useful with files is the ability to be
able to keep track on many of the
metrics and be able to see that faster
startup time there was a regression
introduced which caused the startup time
with their application and to become
very long and so they were able to then
figure out which team is specifically it
caused that issue and then work to be
able to debug that issue the Laveau team
we used the Android voice startup time
and the firebase performance monitoring
tool to be able to really get deep
insights into the startup of their
application so the Android voice covers
the platform level data collection but
doesn't cover exactly in your
application where the issues might occur
and so that's why we encourage you to
use firebase performance monitoring as
well to be able to understand where
specific issues are occurring they were
able to figure out that their login and
signup flow is taking way too long and
they decide to a rewrite of that part of
the application so what's in vials today
so vitals consists of five performance
areas which think you all agree are
things that you don't like to have
happen when you're using apps you don't
want them to crash you don't do drain
all your battery you don't want them to
have to be slow and rendering our
requesting permission so they don't need
our be slow to start and so we have 15
metrics covering these five performance
areas today and across each of these
metrics we provides free dimension
breakdown at a minimum so we show you
OS version I your apk breakdown and
device breakdown and where relevant we
provide other information as well when
it's possible
a new feature that we launched at i/o
this year is category benchmarks this is
where you can now be able to see
compared to other apps in your category
how do you stack up relatively soap to
the Europeans every single metric and we
give you the 25th 75th and even 50th
percentile breakdown for each of those
category benchmarks and that can really
help you be able to understand okay
this metric I'm doing okay on and and
this one I'm actually falling way behind
I need to invest there I mentioned the
anomaly alert emails earlier these are
available in the consul state you have
to opt in to receive them and so I
encourage you if you're not operating
already to sign up today and encourage
the rest of your team to sign up as well
and this is where we notify you and
there's a significant change in the a
nor a crash rate of your application
where we have a spike in the clusters
are across at the core vials which I'm
gonna talk about right now there are 15
Android biometrics it's a lot of metrics
we think all of them are important to
deliver the best possible user
experience but some are more important
than others as talked about earlier the
leading contributions to one star
reviews are civilians and battery issues
so we four core vials that are divided
between those two areas so crash rate
and ANR rate in our eight being
application not responding are the two
civilians and stuck partial wakelocks
and excessive wake-ups being in the two
in the battery area for each core vital
we provide you a bad behavior treshold
this is where if you're above that
threshold you're sort of failing the
class that bad behavior threshold is
established by looking at the top
thousand apps and seeing ok the bottom
25% of apps have are above this rate and
so though that's where the bad behavior
is
we launched the pre-launch report a
couple years ago this is where when you
upload your apk to the Play console test
tracks we will generate a report within
an hour of how your application performs
across those different ten Android
devices that we have in the test lab
when a robot is navigating your
application for about ten minutes it
gives you a report showing you a
screenshot clustering and a bunch of
insights into accessibility issues and
privacy issues also flags crashes one
thing we recently did is that we enabled
you when you look at a crash cluster in
the vital section to be able to see if
we have a pre-launch report crash that
we've detected that matches that crash
from the field this is pretty useful
because with the pre-launch report these
are test lab devices so there aren't the
same privacy restrictions in place as
there are which the data from the field
of course and so here we can be able to
show you the video of the robot
interacting with your application so you
can be able to quickly reproduce that
issue yourself and we provide a lot more
logs and detailed information we also
did the reverse so we now have the
ability to be able to see when you're
looking at a pre-launch report is this a
crash that is already happening in the
field or is this one that maybe just was
introduced with my latest apk but that
hasn't actually reached users yet we
have over 100k developers using android
vitals today hands up here who's using
android violence
cool great thank you guys for using it
and one of the things that I found most
interesting about at this project is
that we've now expanded the number of
users who are using performance metrics
are what we call him like engineering
metrics so I was previously working on
apps on another team at Google and I was
also did that external to Google before
and one of the things I really struggled
with was understanding how these metrics
we're doing because you had to have the
latest version of the code and be able
to run the profilers and now we've made
it so that it's really easy for all the
people in your company to be able to get
access to these performance metrics and
be able to see how you're doing
relatively so to other people and make
the case for investing here versus you
know
the features I've shown some case
studies from different titles here and
as you'd expect you have an Android
engineer head of mobile engineering a
product manager using it but now we have
lead mobile product managers using
performance metrics we have a CTO VP a
product and even CEO OS using
engineering metrics and so I encourage
you and your teams all to start using
these metrics in your conversations with
your senior leadership and and with the
wider team and if you don't probably
gonna get left behind because quality
equals the whole Android ecosystem is
improving anyway I think okay that's
great that's impacting those other
developers but it's not impacting me my
apps awesome even though it says it has
a high crash rate I don't believe you
well we've looked at at the data of
users who experienced a high crash rate
versus users who experience the lower
medium crash rate and what we find is
that users who have a higher crash rate
for the same app leave 52 percent more
one-star review it was our ratings and
then users wished a lower medium one and
so really I would encourage you to start
using file stay if you're not great so
what is the in the future of Android
vials well we've built a lot of features
as you can tell so far and so really the
future of Android vials is you guys
using the product and and so what we're
gonna do is right now we're gonna try
something different and I want everyone
to stand up and I talked to the people
beside you so try and find stuff yeah
and find something beside you who
hopefully have not worked with and just
introduce yourself and we're gonna take
two minutes from one person to talk
about their voice and how they're
approaching it and who in their company
uses it what are the best practices
evolved and then switch role after two
minutes I'll give you two minutes now
and then we'll switch over so yeah so I
hope you learned something from the
people you talk to and made a new friend
hopefully as well all right so I would
encourage you to talk to other people
about how they're approaching their
Voyles there's a lot of documentation
available online to help you as well and
yeah we'll be asked
a booth outside afterwards just on the
right-hand side when you walk out of
this room if you have any questions as
well one of the things that you probably
I realized talking to the person is that
one of the biggest problems with viola
state is actionability and we've heard
you guys and your feedback we really
appreciate that and I wanted to assure
you that that is something that we're
working hard to improve and we will have
more to come on that in the future we do
believe that the data is valid in terms
of telling you the direction to go as in
like you're doing good or bad versus
other people and but we think we can do
better in terms of helping you actually
be more efficient at fixing the problem
but that is a really hard problem and
we're working on changes to the whole OS
itself but those things take a while to
propagate across the Android user base
and then to have enough data to be able
to share back what you would in the
console but it's definitely something we
are working on want to thank you all
very much for joining us today and best
luck with improving your vitals and I
hope I get to share your vial success
stories in our talk next year thank you
[Applause]
[Music]